but I also wanted to kind of talk about
Peter Thiel a little bit because I know
you were closely associated with him I
don't know if you still are he's kind of
a Libertarian some people call him more
of an internationalist how would you
kind of pick his political understanding
and what's kind of his response to
everything that's happening right now I
mean the New York Times calls Peter and
me far-right nationalists you know so
it's like are you an internationalist
are you far right nationalist you know
those are kind of incompatible are you
libertarian or are you an authoritarian
right so it's it's so publicly confused
I think Peter like me started very
libertarian and you know to the extent
uh we play in electoral politics it's
Republican conservative
um but I think you know you can't really
reduce him to labels like that like he's
actually kind of an independent thinker
imagine that right you can't just we
don't have that now increasingly we
don't that's really dangerous and and
one problem in electoral politics that
I've seen is man you're supposed to
really stay on script and if you know
and sometimes I didn't and I paid for
that you know and it was kind of
conventionally speaking it was a mistake
but the problem in modern politics is
you're not allowed to be wrong ever
because if there's two seconds of video
where you say something wrong maybe
you're an exploring an idea right but if
that's wrong and if it's cuttable and
pastable into a into an attack ad that
Mark Kelly and the Democrat machine puts
30 million behind well that's a problem
for you but if you're never allowed to
be wrong then you're never allowed to
think which is why so many politicians
feel like wind-up dolls right robots
that just say the say the thing that the
Consultants wrote and that's safe and
then like what kind of politics does
that produce the kind of politics we've
had and it fails people outside of uh
the tremendous amount of money he made
for the social ramifications do you
think uh Peter Thiel is has concerns
about funding Facebook or regrets or
PayPal yeah PayPal especially yeah well
I think it is probably really sad to see
I mean because PayPal he hasn't been
involved in since 2001 I think 2002 they
sold it to eBay and to see it become I
mean hey this extremely profitable
business right uh that's probably nice
but to see it become this woke horrible
and PayPal is one of the worst and I
know Peter agrees with that and so
that's got to be hard to create this
thing and it's your baby and then all of
a sudden it's like ruined by watching
your kid go to college and come back
with a shaved head and like pink
eyebrows telling you how racist and
bigoted
it's gonna be horrible um Facebook I
mean Facebook was a really good
investment 2004 he you know he's it was
it was a good investment and then he he
sort of rode the wave and saw it become
like this really charismatic company
2008 2012. his book was going to take
over the world 2014 right when we wrote
this book about zero to one monopolies
kind of warning people hey monopolies
can be good you know they can also be
really really bad
um I think Facebook is has been net very
destructive for the past five or six
years and ultimately Peter hopped off
the board right so it's this whole life
cycle I think starting in around 2008
Facebook started getting really really
really bad it was it was the the
beginning of the algorithmic news feed
when people started having too many
friends and liking too many pages and so
the feed was just moving too quickly uh
I could be wrong with my understanding
is Facebook started to implement an
algorithm where it would feed you more
of what you they thought you would like
to see to keep you on the platform
chamber confirmation exactly then you
see the transformation of the buzzfeeds
the Huffington posts they started
adhering and fall and molding themselves
to the algorithm and the best example of
this is mike.com which when it started
was was Pro Ron Paul but quickly
realized the algorithm favored wokeness
and it's for it's a really really simple
mathematical equation right
in the beginning of the internet or
actually it's in the beginning but in in
the late 2000s early 2010s the Ron Paul
Revolution was in full swing it was it
was a meme it was viral people believed
in it the algorithm starts becoming more
prominent and what happens is Rage
inducing content gets more clicks and
gets more shares so police brutality
videos start going viral this
contributes to a lot of the libertarian
thinking
but then something happens if you make a
video about racism it goes virally make
a video about police brutality it goes
viral so that's uh you know X views and
Y views but you make a racist police
brutality video now it's XY views it is
Multiplied it is bigger all of a sudden
you start seeing articles from like Vice
where it's like you know
um gay people uh gay trans people of
color are the the strongest argument in
favor of black lives matter to cram all
of those words into one article to
maximize algorithmic pressure and you
end up with intersectionality and
wokeness being Amplified monetized and
profitable
people hijack the really weak artificial
or the machine learning algorithms and
then when they went prop uh public
Facebook went public they started
charging people money to to get your own
followers to see you as part of this
that's right algorithmic boost I
remember in 2011 we were working with
mines and this this Facebook group
called um exposing the truth which was
hugely popular and then as soon as they
went public man no views and everyone
everything was pay pay pay-per-view what
happened when Facebook went public we
had Vivek ramaswamy on the other night
and he was saying they were expected to
have like a 55 public offering when they
go public I suppose stocks supposed to
be 55 it came out at like 18 bucks and
then he said it was like a wealth
distribution thing like intentionally
they well you I think that the point of
the conversation was maybe that was the
exit for you know intelligence or other
uh nefarious entities that wanted to get
their money out of the machine somehow
like they wanted people that were honest
Brokers to baby like oh I'm bailing on
this and then or just to not buy or
something they were dumping their their
connection to it bad time to dump
because mean Facebook stock exploded and
that you're subsequent to the IPO
you realize you did not want to sell I
mean what is it currently I haven't
checked lately but and I want to say
2013 2014 2015 that stock did incredibly
well what were you doing with Peter
Thiel I know you're working with him in
San Francisco what was your role uh just
managing the the family office you know
just always trying to find the next
thing to invest in and so his his
investment company teal management
company and the cool thing about Peter
is while he's I think the world's best
venture capitalist right or certainly
top three but I think he's the best um
he's always you know it's like
one minute you're talking about what to
what to invest in the next minute you're
talking about you know China yeah and
and what's going to happen in 30 years
and then peak oil and like what's the
deal with that and then he's just he's
truly intellectually omnivorous is he a
peak oil believer uh I
have to ask him I think he would have
said yes 10 years ago and no not so much
it's a very contentious idea that I
believe uh I don't I don't actually
believe in but would you say his
principles are more aligned with uh
making money or sharing kind of his
larger uh libertarian more right-wing
ideas because when you have you know so
much power and influence you're either
motivated by let's make all this money
or let's let's promote these principles
he did support he did have uh I think
backing of Ron Paul and then went and
supported Donald Trump
um in the last election so I was just
wondering from your perspective and if
it's too personal you don't know it's
too personal I mean I don't want to
speak for him he'd probably come up with
some cut why those were like actually
you know not mutually exclusive and why
they actually compound if you if you
pursue both goals at the same time or
something like that being has to find
Peak oil what is that that that's a
theory that there's the oil is going to
be running out there's not going to be
enough oil and therefore we need to get
off oil immediately because I think it's
true I just I think the question is how
much oil obviously there's a finite
amount there's a fine night Earth so the
question is is there so little oil that
we might run out
or is it that it is finite but there's
so much human could never begin to
consume all of it yeah I don't believe
it to be true because a lot of the
science is also backed by a lot of the
people who are saying you know the
world's going to end in a few years
because of the climate so we see a lot
of the same rhetoric for the same people
we always it's a it's a decade it's
always a new problem it's always a new
controversy yeah there's an alarmism
right too that never quite pans out ioc
saying the world's going to end yeah the
ocean levels are gonna rise the ice is
going to the and then it was the ozone
layer a couple decades before that and
then what was it a couple decades before
that there was always something going on
Cooling in this global cooling yeah
global warming it was always not a good
argument in my opinion because a bunch
of regulations were put in place the
ncfc's the ozone is fine now yeah but
the sensationalism so that that actually
gives them brownie points when you make
that argument because they're like oh
yeah we banned the things causing that
we fixed it so I I I say you know look
it's it's not uh um one or the other we
had global cooling now we have global
warming that gives me pause the ozone
layer things an entirely different issue
yes I'm just so I'm just talking about
the kind of talking points when people
are saying the world is going to end
every decade we should that was one of
the talking points and the parameters of
what you were described we just got to
start a new one we got to start like um
how about global tremoring acid rain is
also another artificial intelligence
that's what Global tremoring uh more
earthquakes are going to happen because
uh cracking
that's that that's a real one yeah
that's a real one too you know but I was
going to say like the the the the the
earthquake in San Andreas the San
Andreas fault's gonna go because insert
human activity here it's all the uh it's
all the humans doing jump rope jumping
up and down shaking the ground it's
gonna stop no more no more exercise real
one is we might get hit by meteors if we
just sit around on our hands for the
next 300 years
um it wiped out previous civilizations
solar flare
solar flare is going to wipe out all of
our electrical equipment hard to tie
that one back to human causes but it's
you know that's why it's always
considered it's the TV it's all of the
the radio waves we're messing with the
yeah that's bouncing around the two real
ones one
um which is which is more of a slow boil
is China I really do think China is a is
a existential threat long term
unfortunately right we're already in
some kind of cold war with China and we
need to make sure we win that so that we
never get into a hot war with China and
then speaking of hot words nuclear power
I still are a nuclear um War I still
think we're underpricing the risk to
having the Russia Ukraine situation
escalate into an all-out nuclear war
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time